So just to recap, our circles, while we bound them and
they were on the page, they had no x or y position, radius, or fill color.
So what this chunk of code basically says in English is, for
each data point or circle, change its x position, according to its date and
its y position according to its attendance.
Add an attribute of radius.
In this case it's a radius of three as we said previously.
And fill it with a color.
In this case blue.
Before I move on I just wanted to make one more point
about the anonymous accessor functions.
I'll go over rather a different way of looking at them.
While you can think of these as any other function it takes some input
in this case D which corresponds to an individual row from our data and
gives some output, in this case, for
the exposition of pixel value returned from the time scale.
I often like to think of the accessor functions as analogous to the properties
of a class, for folks who are comfortable with object-oriented programming, or
in a more simple sense, simply a variable.
In this case, the accessor function for setting the exposition returns
a variable value depending on what data point gets passed into it.
So again while you can put some logic to transform your data or
perform some other actions inside of the accessor function,
typically I only use in the sense of pulling out some data.
And returning some value, that's dependent on that value I pulled out.
So in most of the uses of this anonymous accessor functions in D3,
it's often useful to think of them as some data dependent value.
Based on what the bound data is,
the accessor function should return some value derived from the data.
And again this allows us to customize each function for each data point.
In this case for datum one placed at the x position of datum one's date.
For datum two placed at the exposition of datum two's date and so forth all
the way to datam 836 or however many pieces of data you have in your data set.